our next guest jean she just turned 50
and wanted to try jumping out of a plane
for the very first time and i actually
have experience jumping from a plane i
went skydiving with my
bff okay i'm not dropping names it just
happens to be cameron diaz
but no one told me how it was really
going to feel so i called jean up to
offer her some advice
that i wish someone had told me and i
was with her every step of the way
take a look
i get to go skydiving today and jump out
of a plane
um i'm extremely thrilled and excited
and i won't lie i'm a little bit scared
at the same time i'm skydiving baby
yes
hi jean i'm so excited for you
what inspired you to do this i just
turned 50
last month in september and i am an
adventurous person
by heart and so this was just the
perfect way for me to kick off a new
decade
being 50 jumping out of a plane
skydiving so my husband doesn't know but
i think when i'm 60 i might do jumpy
uh bungee jumping can i tell you
something
i'm gonna get straight to the point no
one told me this
have you ever um put your mouth over a
leaf blower
i don't think i have why you're about to
the one thing that no one tells you
about skydiving
is take a very big breath right before
you jump out because i didn't and the
wind
you literally are gonna feel like this
is your husband there with you yes he is
and he's so excited
nice to meet you i noticed you're not in
a suit
uh no i'm not now why aren't you going
today
uh yeah you know i think it was just uh
trying to coordinate coming up here
uh i think she's trying to say you can't
you should go today you're she's saying
i can go
i think i'm gonna go today seriously
this is happening
i'm so excited for you guys i think
it'll be so much fun
mike have you ever put your mouth over a
leaf blower
[Music]
so
[Music]
i cannot even describe the feeling it
was incredible
oh my god okay is he
[Music]
[Applause]
it oh okay us after their very first
time
skydiving is gene and mike
hi guys
hi how are you i love watching your
videos so much
i mean you see like the wind force
that i'm speaking of yes thoughts
feelings well i actually took your
advice
and took a deep breath before i jumped
out of the plane
and for the rest of my ride i tried to
concentrate on my breathing which
really actually helped but you can see
i'm trying to
smile and breathe and my face was
shaking
it was just an incredible thrilling
experience
oh i'm so glad that you had a positive
experience and that you could breathe
because i was literally like i'm gonna
die from not
taking a breath for two minutes i didn't
i
was like i haven't checked how long i
can hold my breath
and now i need to know in the most
serious situation mike what was it like
for you
it was a thrill for a lifetime now can i
ask
what your ride home was like because i
swear
i'm not name dropping it's just sort of
and i i just don't have a lot of famous
friends i grew up in hollywood
but i made best friends with like
cameron diaz when we were like 14 and 16
like we've known each other forever
so people happen to know her name but
she's just my friend
like one of my best friends my sister
and we went skydiving together
and that ride home we felt really
invincible i'm not gonna lie how did you
feel on the ride home
i i'd have to agree with that we felt
like after that we could probably do
um anything and my son was really bummed
that he wasn't able to do it with us so
we get to experience it again i think
probably next year sometime with him oh
i love that
oh how old is your son by the way 17.
oh perfect yeah he's fearless he's had a
lot of adventures with us so yeah
well i love that you guys are so
adventurous and i love that you guys got
to share this because
i remember we like i had my like feet
outside the car window and i was just
like kicking back and i felt
super immortal super invincible and like
i could face anything like i just
conquered everest
after skydiving yeah we were just like
did we just do this did we just jump out
of a plane it was just such a surreal
experience
um something that we will always
remember for the rest of our lives
absolutely
a story to tell our grandkids hopefully
not too soon in the future but someday
we will be able to tell our grandkids
about this
well i hope you had a hot makeout
because that is some serious like
aphrodisiac foreplay skydiving i'm just
saying
you're like oh my god we can do anything
very exciting well i really loved
getting to be a part of your journey
and i just had this one life experience
with my girlfriend
and i've really not gotten to revisit it
or share it or
relive it and thanks to you gene and
mike
i feel like i got to be a part of your
journey and go back in time
to a moment that i will never forget
if it's something you do once it lives
with you forever
absolutely absolutely and thank you for
allowing us to share our experience
um and having us on your show is
definitely something we won't forget for
the rest of our lives
oh gene and mike thank you for saying
that
so much it's been so much fun getting to
know you
and i love watching you jump out of a
plane and i really want to welcome you
guys to the skydivers club
so i had these custom skydiving suits
made for you
um with your names on the back oh that's
so cool
oh look at that i love it that like both
the
like left arms are red that's kind of an
interesting detail
but did you ever for one second think
why am i defying death
um oh many times of course but uh that's
what it's about
you um you know we're when you're
adventurous and you've done
previous things that you know when your
adrenaline is pumping yeah of course
but i will not regret this and hopefully
i'll get to do it again soon
after now yeah yeah we have our own
customers
yeah by the way now we need to make one
for your son and we want to thank our
friends
in philly at skydive philadelphia for
coordinating this jump and making this
dream come true
gina mike thank you for letting us tag
along
and thank you so much for being on the
show you guys this was so fun oh
for us too thank you absolutely pleasure
thank you
thank you